♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden is facing
criticism after he fist-bumped
Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman
last week during their
first in-person meeting.
Of course, at this point,
that's like saying
"Mosquitos are
facing criticism."
When weren't they?
[ Light laughter ]
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
apologized last week,
after she said that
the Latino community is, quote,
"as unique as the breakfast
tacos here in San Antonio."
[ Laughter ]
Said Biden in her apology,
"I'm as sorry
as the breakfast tacos
at Taco Bell."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump and
former Vice President
Mike Pence are set to hold
competing rallies on Friday
in Arizona.
It will be the first time
they've faced off
since January 6th.
[ Audience ohs ]
Jennifer Lopez and Ben Affleck
over the weekend
reportedly got married.
Guests were offered beef,
chicken,
or bacon, egg, and cheese.
[ Light laughter ]
I felt really good
about that joke earlier.
[ Laughter ]
You know what,
it's for a certain --
it's for a certain region
of America.
[ Light laughter ]
Hope you enjoy it, New England!
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Ben Affleck
and Jennifer Lopez
reportedly got married over
the weekend, because right now,
that's the only way a Red Sox
fan can get a win in the Bronx.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Audience oohs ]
Wow. I took it right --
I took it right back.
Told a joke for New England
that bombed in New York,
And then [bleep] 'em
with the next joke.
[ Laughter ]
Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
announced recently
that the coffee chain will close
16 stores due to rising crime.
The most egregious crime?
Waiting until you're
at the front of the line
before looking at the menu.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, so the sizes
are in Italian."
[ Laughter ]
The fast food restaurant Subway
recently changed the names
of several of its sandwiches,
including switching
the meatball marinara
to "The Boss,"
as opposed to what's usually
called "the boss" at Subway --
a 16-year-old kid.
[ Laughter ]
Lego recently announced
that they will release
a new set based on the sitcom
"The Office."
Though, if your kid wants that,
bad news, they're a Dwight.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, producers have
announced that a reboot
of the procedural
"Criminal Minds" will air
on the streaming service
Paramount+.
So if you're a big fan of
detective work,
try and figure out how to watch
Paramount+.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
some of President Biden's
top allies are quietly meeting
with Democratic officials
and donors
ahead of the 2024 election
in case he doesn't run.
Well, quietly,
aside from the person
who keeps coughing the word
"Hillary."
[ Laughter ]
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
met today with
Ukrainian First Lady
Olena Zelenska
at the White House.
"Sorry for everything your
country is going through,"
said Zelenska.
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk was photographed
over the weekend
aboard a luxury yacht
in Mykonos, Greece,
and all I can say is wow!
He is...
He is so white,
the sun had to put on sunscreen!
[ Laughter ]
He looks like
the page in the coloring book
you haven't gotten to yet.
[ Laughter ]
Is he partying on that yacht...
or is he haunting it?
[ Laughter ]
I will say, though --
I will say, he does have
the skin tone of somebody who
is very good with technology.
[ Laughter ]
Steven Spielberg recently
directed his first music video
using his smartphone,
which is surprising
because most people his age
record concerts on their iPads.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
a couple who has been married
for nearly 80 years
said that their secret
to a long-lasting relationship
is always sharing a kiss
before bedtime.
"Same," said those freaks
from "Willy Wonka."
[ Laughter ]
New York Governor Kathy Hochul
announced yesterday
she will expand
shark-patrol crews
amid an increase
of attacks on Long Island.
Meanwhile, Republican governors
are encouraging residents
to buy sharks for protection.
[ Laughter ]
The only thing
that stops a shark
is a good guy with a shark.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
11% of Americans said that
their favorite ice-cream flavor
is vanilla.
Well, if you love vanilla,
I got good news for you!
There it is!
That was a monologue, you guys.
The White House is reportedly
considering major changes
for its communications team.
For example,
they're going to get one.
[ Laughter ]
The National Archives yesterday
asked the Secret Service
to provide information
about the deletion
of agents' text messages
pertaining
to the Capitol attack.
Who's laughing now...
said the one agent
with an Android
who wasn't allowed
in the group chat.
[ Laughter ]
Britain's Prince William
and Duchess Kate Middleton
announced today
that they will travel to Boston
later this year.
This news was first reported
by Paul Revere.
[ Laughter ]
Former New York mayor
Bill de Blasio
announced yesterday he's ending
his congressional campaign,
and I'm guessing this is
not how Bill de Blasio
wanted everyone to learn
he had a congressional campaign.
[ Laughter ]
Today was
National Pennsylvania Day.
"Where the hell is that?"
asked Dr. Oz.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new list, Vermont
is the best state to live in.
Well, no wonder.
He always looks so happy.
[ Laughter ]
Netflix reported yesterday
that it lost nearly
1 million subscribers
in the last three months.
Well, Netflix, I think you
finally have your answer.
[ Laughter ]
Two governing bodies
of quidditch have announced
that they will change the name
of the sport to quadball
in an effort to distance
themselves from J.K. Rowling.
Said bullies, "Fine,
let's go beat up
the quadball players, then!"
[ Light laughter ]
When asked about his song
"American Pie"
in a new documentary,
singer Don McLean
said the jester mentioned in
the lyrics is not James Dean.
He also said, "Please,
please don't sing that song
at karaoke."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
after a man recently fell
and injured himself
at Lake Tahoe,
his border collie ran 200 yards
through the remote area
of the forest
to lead rescue crews
to his owner,
while his French bulldog ran
six feet and immediately died.
President Biden tested positive
today for the coronavirus.
Luckily, we've all been
keeping our distance.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, President Biden
tested positive today
for the coronavirus.
So, for the next two weeks,
the country will be hosted
by Chelsea Handler!
[ Laughter ]
She'll do great.
She's a pro.
According to a poll
released yesterday,
President Biden's approval
rating has hit a record low 31%,
putting him below the critical
"yellow Starburst" benchmark.
[ Laughter ]
The House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
help a prime-time hearing
tonight
and offered a timeline of what
former President Trump did
at the White House
during the insurrection.
We tape early,
but I'm guessing...
watched TV?
[ Laughter ]
That's like finding out
what Joey Chestnut did
on Fourth of July.
Same thing that he always does.
Former Vice President Mike Pence
spoke yesterday
at a South Carolina church
and said that the best part
of no longer being in office
is that he gets to drive
his own car,
and he made it very clear
that he drives an automatic
because it's a sin
to drive stick.
[ Laughter ]
His words, not ours.
I mean...
Authorities in Spain this week
arrested two thieves
who allegedly stole
45 bottles of wine from a hotel
that were worth
nearly $2 million.
Even worse, they stole
the Toblerone from the minibar,
valued at $3 million.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the Mega Millions
lottery jackpot
hit $630 million this week
after there were no winners.
Whoever wins it this week
can take the jackpot
in installments,
a lump sum,
or premium unleaded.
[ Laughter ]
Ohh! [ Laughs ]
That was a monologue, everybody.